my mom had just taken me on this great
shopping spree for my birthday and I
bought these clothes I walked into the
lunchroom and everyone made so much fun
of me I felt so ashamed the fact that I
was different there are just so many
specifics that have stuck with me to
this day that have really instilled a
sense of like fear I had a Pocahontas
backpack and I loved that book on his
backpack I wore to school and got ripped
and everyone got made fun of me and it
just became a routine where I would come
home from elementary school crying I was
teased growing up for being gay before I
even knew that I was gay fourth grade
only played with girls at recess and my
teacher took me out of class and talked
to me and was like you should really
hang out with other boys sometimes and I
remember being like why are you telling
me who I should hang out with and why
does it matter growing up in elementary
I was on with the girls but I did
actually like them at that time I had a
crush on like almost every girl at the
table i sat with at one point I just you
it's a fredholm I remember the jock guys
always telling me like oh you're gay and
like gay and people make you in front of
me not only because they assumed I was
gay because I was overweight I was asked
growing up like if I was and I was like
oh my god are they gonna find out
growing up you hear stories about gay
people getting killed on the street and
like that happens still now yes
horrifying I was bullied in middle
school by somebody who eventually came
out and he would bully me for being gay
which was him projecting on to me his
insecurities
I think being bullied for being gay just
kind of confirmed that I didn't want to
come out of the closet I was afraid of
coming out and admitting to myself into
the world like who I really am I don't
know if that kind of trickled down into
like my adulthood now I'm sure it has
because everything that we experience in
our lives like affects us in one way or
another
I don't show PDA when I'm on the street
like I don't hold hands I'm afraid that
society is gonna regress and then all of
a sudden there's gonna be laws about
being gay gay people are getting shot
gay people like attack oh it's okay to
hate people who aren't like you I
definitely do feel like already a shift
back I still haven't let it overwhelm me
with fear yet but it is like this little
thing nagging me in the back of my head
like is it still okay for you to be
yourself all the time are you gonna get
a rock thrown at your head if you like
hold your boyfriend's hand I think for
me the biggest fear that I have is that
the younger generation kind of coming up
people in their teens and 20s have had
it pretty good like they've seen so much
change in the past ten years and where
being gay is very accepted and almost a
norm in society and they don't know how
hard it has been to fight for those
things some of those rights can still be
taken away and they are even me like a
difference between you I know it's not
the big age difference but there's a lot
of very privileged gay kids growing up
now you could literally tell them over
this person helped with this movement
I'm like oh I don't care about and you
know they should because that's the
reason why they can be so
idgaf on Instagram and I don't care
haters and this and that because of
people like that that have fought for me
for me especially it felt like you're
not accepted you're gay you're gay gay
and all sudden wow gates get married
it's cool again we forget about the
middle of the country and the students
out there who can't be protected and I
think that there's still a lot of work
to do it's starting to be more mindful
of the laws that protect people like me
and little kids out there who need it
[Music]
I think when I first came out I was like
oh yeah it'd be a lot easier if I were
straight
I have never wished I was straight I
remember going to sleep sometimes I've
been like oh I wish I was straight I was
so straight and like crying and
everything was intense when I met my
current boyfriend I told him that one
day I would marry a girl because at the
time I was not out at all and that's
what I thought I had to do that's what
society tells you please my parents
didn't I a big part of myself now I love
being gay because that's who I am no no
I never wish I was straight never I
absolutely did wish I was straight I
thought when I was younger that being
gay would mean a life of more bullying
as much bullying as I went through and
had to like endure being gay has become
something that I'm so so so proud of but
once you like rip that band-aid off
you're out no I wouldn't change a thing
you come out of the closet and you just
steal that door yeah but a lot of the
time I like forget that being gay is
seen as the abnormal thing because it's
just like what my life is and how I love
living my life and everyone's don't be
like wouldn't it suck if I was straight
because I wouldn't have all this like
great gay sex like no no like I'm so
creative and I love making people laugh
the whole like creative aspect I've
opened and let blossom because I was
honest with myself now that I'm gay and
I see how [ __ ] great it is I would
never wish to be straight we have so
much fun just like my day-to-day life
being gay I can listen to whatever music
I want and it's never a threat to my
sexuality you can be whatever you want
to be compared to things that you can't
do because maybe that would be a little
too gay how proud I am of this person
that I've become and how I feel like I'm
the most me I've ever been I want that
journey for everyone who was a little
gay boy or girl out there who doesn't
feel accepted and I'm definitely so much
more comfortable being gay than I ever
have been especially being in a big city
where it's so accepted I think that
there's still a lot of hate a lot of
people get gay bashed Phil and we don't
always talk about it I'm trying to as a
gay man become much more active and
talking about that and putting an end to
it
I think being gay and overcoming all the
struggles that we have growing up I feel
like I'm a lot more empathetic to
different struggles even if it doesn't
have anything to do with being gay like
you can relate a lot of people are so
obsessed with other people's
relationships and like what they're
doing and they're not even working on
themselves that for me it was kind of a
step to be like don't worry about me
like I'm happy like I'm genuinely happy
so like you should be happy too it's
just more accepting of like other people
and differences and that it's okay that
we might not agree on something even as
gay people because we're both gay but
there's probably we might have
differences in that it's okay and we can
talk through them being in the gay
community has taught me a lot about
transparency and acceptance whoever you
are you can be totally transparent about
who you are and we will accept you when
you're queer you have the freedom to be
as masculine or as feminine as you want
I think having anything that's
inherently a part of who you are that
you have to actively overcome growing up
makes you so strong and I think that
that's what makes me so proud is that I
overcame the obstacles that came along
with being gay and that led me to a
higher place of self-love and that's why
I'm so proud of it I'm also just really
proud of this community and everything
that it stands for
[Applause]
[Music]